this video is made possible by the good
people at brilliance you'll learn more
about brilliant lighter in today's video
but if you want to learn more about them
right now why wouldn't you get a
brilliant adored /bi graphics you'll
also find a link in the description
below it is very rare that a book can
come out and single-handedly change
humanity's understanding of the world
but in 1543 and just a heads up there
are gonna be some Latin pronunciations
in this one surprisingly I don't
actually speak Latin I know you might
expect it but I don't I'm gonna do my
best
the book was called dare revolutionibus
orbital cholesterol the revolutions of
the heavenly spheres and it really
changed the world it was a book by a
Polish astronomer called Nicholas
Copernicus in which he presented a model
of a heliocentric universe one which did
not place the earth at the center of
everything instead it had been replaced
with the Sun which was now more or less
at the heart of the universe and all the
stars and planets in the sky they
revolved around it it was a
revolutionary thought one that
challenged well-established notions that
had been around for over a millennium it
wasn't immediately accepted or even
understood for that matter but it served
its purpose in presenting an alternative
to a grand idea that seemed amou Vibol
from the public consciousness many
others followed who popularized improved
and heavily modified the heliocentric
model first outlined by Copernicus but
it still remains to this day
one of the core concepts of our very
reality
Nicholas Copernicus or nikolayeva Nick
in its original polish was born on
February the 19th 1473 in the city of
Turin in the recently established
territory of royal Prussia prior to this
the region had been a part of the state
of the Teutonic order formed by Crusader
Knights during the 13th century however
following the second piece of turin in
1466 royal prussia became an autonomous
dependency of the kingdom of poland
Copernicus was the son of Nicholas the
elder and Barbara Watson wrote according
to records Nicholas his father was a
successful merchant as was his
grandfather on his mother's side
originally established in Krakow
Nicholas the elder decided to relocate
the family to Tehran before the birth of
his namesake Nicholas was the youngest
in the family with an older brother and
two older sisters the family last name
comes from copper Nicky the village
where his paternal ancestors came from
throughout his lifetime Copernicus was
rather relaxed when it came to the
spelling of his last name and he used at
least three different variants is
unlikely the Copernicus would have had
the opportunity to pursue a life of
science if not for his maternal uncle
Lucas Watson rode the younger the senior
Nicholas died when his son was only 10
years old and his uncle took him and his
siblings in under his care he insured
for a good education for young per
nachus there are no records to suggest
exactly what that entails particularly
in his early years but historians have
speculated that the young man most
likely followed an educational path
similar to that of his uncle this would
have involved studies of the cynjohn
school and to run and then in the
Cathedral School in Vlad si avec in
order to prepare Copernicus for entry
into the University of Krakow Watson
Rhodes alma mater we do know that
Copernicus enrolled in the school in
Krakow today the Jagiellonian University
in the winter of 1491 surprisingly he
first studied arts but also decided to
learn mathematics in order to take
advantage of the fact that the school
had some of the best mathematicians in
Europe this was also the time when he
started going by the latin version of
his name instead of his polish birth
name one of his educators was Albert
Zeb's key math teacher who used to also
give lectures on astronomy and Aristotle
in philosophy he was likely among the
first to spur young Copernicus his
interest in studying the Stars the
polish prodigy quickly proved to have a
knack for mathematics and astronomy and
it was during his time at the University
of Krakow that he wrote his first
observation on the subject Nicolas left
University in 1495 without a degree and
returned home to his uncle a few years
earlier Lukas Watson rode the younger
became the prince Bishop of Vermeer a
special region that was under direct
authority of the Pope unsurprisingly he
wanted to secure a canonical position
for his nephew
however for unknown reasons Copernicus's
assignment was delayed so instead his
uncle sent him to continue his studies
in Italy at the Bologna University
technically Copernicus went to Italy to
study canon law so he could advance his
position in the church something that
would have been almost guaranteed given
his uncle's high standing however in the
year spent in Bologna Nicholas became
more interested in continuing his
studies of astronomy in the humanities
there he met a Domenico Maria navara a
famed astronomer of his time he became
Copernicus's teacher and even took him
on as an assistant
Copernicus travelled for a bit to Rome
where he spent the Jubilee year 1500 by
this point he had become proficient
enough in astronomy that he started
giving lectures the next year the young
scientist returns a Vermeer but the stay
was short-lived he convinced the church
that he should also study medicine so he
was given another two-year leave to go
back to Italy this time he enrolled at
the University of Dewar from 1501 to
1503 like before Copernicus was not one
to limit his knowledge to the intended
curriculum and he pursued multiple
interests which of course included
astronomy but also ancient Greek which
would give him access to many of the
seminal astronomical works from ancient
times despite all of his extracurricular
activities the second time around in
Italy Nikolas managed to graduate as a
doctor of law with his studies complete
the 30 year old Copernicus returned to
Vermeer where he would spend most of his
next 40 years he became his uncle's
right and Men officially he was the
Prince bishops assistant and physician
although he was involved with most of
the duties of his uncle be they
religious economical political or
administrative it is unclear if he was
ever actually ordained as a priest but
it does not seem like he ever took
from the Catholic Church with all of his
responsibilities Copernicus was a busy
man he was on the road a lot as part of
his uncle's retinue even so in the eight
years or so that he served Lucas Vartan
road until his death he still managed to
write a small precursor to his later
work which would revolutionize astronomy
[Music]
we should probably take a minute here to
look at humanity's understanding of the
universe
prior to Copernicus to truly get a sense
of how influential II was in the grand
scheme of things before he published his
seminal work
the astronomical world believed in a
geocentric model this meant that the
earth was at the center of the universe
and everything else moons planets stars
are very Sun they all orbited us this
belief appeared in many ancient cultures
including the Greeks they were presented
more or less the basic tenants of
geocentrism but there was no widely
accepted system that is until an
astronomer from Alexandria named
Claudius Ptolemy wrote the Almagest
around sometime in the mid 2nd century
AD and we should make a quick note here
even though is sometimes referred to as
Ptolemy and he was from Alexandria he
should not be confused with any members
of the Ptolemaic dynasty that ruled over
Egypt for almost 300 years and also
included Cleopatra the astronomer wrote
his seminal work which he called
Mathematica sin taxes or the
mathematical compilation despite his
name it was mostly about the motions of
the stars and the planets and as it grew
in influence it became known as the
greatest compilation the name was then
shortened to the greatest and later when
it made its way into other cultures it
was more commonly referred to by its
Latin transliteration of Almagest
although the Almagest consisted of 13
books it had five main points the
celestial realm was spherical our earth
was a sphere at the center of this realm
did not move and in relation to the
distance to all the fixed stars the
earth had no appreciable size and must
have been treated as a mathematical
point Ptolemy his ideas were popular
enough that eventually the Ptolemaic
model became synonymous with geocentrism
it was the accepted truth for 1,300
years but it still had its detractors
even before Copernicus there were rather
astray
particularly in the medieval Arab well
to soar floors in Ptolemies system
however none of them went so far as to
propose an alternate theory that
completely negated it ok so just before
we continue today I do want to take a
quick moment to thank our rather
appropriate sponsor for this video
brilliant brilliant believes that
learning maths science and computer
science doesn't have to be dull to that
end they've put to get the courses that
are all about storytelling interactive
challenges and solving problems it's
basically a hands-on approach that is a
really excellent way to learn and
currently they've got over 50
interactive courses I mean look you're
halfway through a video that is very
heavy on sine so you're probably already
too curious type and brilliant
it can be a great way to take that
curiosity a step further and start
really understanding the world around us
for example you can check out their
course on astronomy it's rather
appropriate to this video it covers
loads of stuff going beyond just the
foundations like gravity but also
looking at more modern concepts like
dark matter and dark energy so effective
learning it's all about problem solving
and brilliant help you learn and
practice just that it's a great
complement to videos like this one I
mean it's all good to learn something
here but you can take it a bit of a step
deeper with brilliant so if you want to
support via graphics which would be
amazing and get unlimited access to all
of brilliance in depth maths and science
courses just deliver two brilliant elorg
/by graphics and you'll get 20% off
their premium and your subscription and
let's get back to it
[Music]
because the Almagest had been around
folk well over a thousand years and
travelled from culture to culture it had
been translated many times from one
language to another written originally
in Greek it was converted to Arabic by
Muslim scholars and later medieval
Europeans used that version and
translated it into Latin many
astronomers pratik Bernanke's thought
that it might contain inaccuracies not
necessarily due to Ptolemies faulty
ideas but due to poor translations one
of them was a German scientist screwed
regiomontanus he obtains the original
Greek work and concluded that there were
errors in fact which belonged to Ptolemy
rather than the translators who came
after him he published the summary of
Ptolemy's Almagest several years before
Copernicus was even born the Polish
astronomer he read regiomontanus book he
had also been spurred on by his teacher
in Bologna navara who was another
skeptic who doubted ptolemies
infallibility Copernicus was determined
to study the ancient Greek astronomer
himself and draw his own conclusions
sometime before 1514 Copernicus wrote a
treatise called the coment arias little
commentary consisting of eight chapters
it made arguments for seven postulates
that laid down the groundwork for his
heliocentric model crucially they said
that the earth is not the center of the
universe and that there is no fixed
point around which all other steel
bodies orbit the paper got some things
right such as the fact that the moon is
the only sphere that orbits the earth
and that the distance from the earth to
the Sun is insignificant compared to the
distance of all the other stars
Copernicus also placed the known planets
in the right order from the Sun and
calculated their orbital periods with
pretty impressive accuracy it also got
some things wrong though such as placing
the Sun near the center of the universe
and concluding that the stars are a
moveable even so these radical ideas
were very far removed from the accepted
model of Ptolemy Copernicus surahs
comentario lists as just an outline for
a much grander work therefore he did not
make many copies of his treatise and
only shared it with a few people there
was never published during his lifetime
among those who did receive a copy of
the paper it received a good reception
it was a particular interest you
Nicholas von Schoenberg an archbishop
and later a cardinal of Pope Paul the
third in 1536
letter to Copernicus requesting a copy
of his treatise he praised the
astronomers so fine a talents and
expressed great interest in his
revolutionary ideas
Copernicus later included this letter in
his magnum opus revolutionibus orbit
uncle STM the pointers scientist he was
not one to rush into things after he
wrote their commentary LS he would spend
another two decades working on his main
treatise there would be another decade
after that that they would finally get
printed in the same year that Copernicus
died he was mainly concerned with his
astronomical observations but Copernicus
also had plenty of administrative duties
to attend to which ate up a lot of his
time his uncle the Prince Bishop of
Omiya died in 1512 and - Nicholas
participated in the election of his
successor
there were also other issues that
required his attention such as the
renewed war with the Teutonic order and
internal strife among the leaders of
Maumee are ever how loyal and Serbians
they should be towards the Polish crown
around this time Copernicus also
relocated permanently to the city of
from Bork where he lived and worked for
the remainder of his life he not only
had a house but was also allowed to
purchase the northwestern tower within
the stronghold walls to use as his
Observatory often overlooked is
Copernicus's contribution to economics
bears mentions before he wore many hats
as his uncle's right-hand man when Lucas
Watson Road passed away his nephew
proved adept enough that he continued to
be a major influence in the
administration of Vermeer in 1526 he was
asked by King sysem on the first of
Poland to write a paper on monetary
reform which was a hot-button topic at
the time Copernicus wrote monitor-kun
and a ratio which in English is on the
minting of coin the gist of it is
exemplified by the principle that bad
money drives out good in this case good
money refers to coins whose face value
is roughly the same as their commodity
value granted by the value of the metals
that they are made from bad money refers
to coins that not only have a
significant disparity between the two
values that are also put in circulation
alongside good money a bit unfairly the
postulate is known today as Gresham's
lon names in the 19th century after 16th
century English financier Sir Thomas
Gresham
however Copernicus
published his work on the subject
decades before crashing
[Music]
by the early 1530s Copernicus's seminal
work tear revolutionibus orbit uncle s
tiem was finished more or less he kept
on making changes to it until his death
but it could have been ready for
printing if he desired it
however the Polish astronomer kept on
delaying the publication of the book and
even today scholars argue over the true
reason for this behavior some feel that
it had to do with the church and that
Copernicus
feared the consequences that might occur
if his work was deemed heretical after
all things did not work out so well for
Galileo almost a hundred years later his
ideas were considered heresy by the
Roman Inquisition because heliocentrism
contradicted the Holy Scripture and as a
result Galileo was forced to recant his
views and spent the last decade of his
life under house arrest others believed
that Copernicus was reticent to publish
his findings because he feared any kind
of criticism or outright rejection of
his ideas
ever since Copernicus wrote the
commentary onus he was careful to share
his work only with his friends and other
trusted astronomers he did the same
thing with dare evolution abyss orbit
uncle STM prior to printing but word of
mouth spread and as others heard of it
bishops knew about it and so did the
Pope initial reactions seemed to be
either of approval or indifference there
were plenty of people astronomers
included who disagreed with his ideas
but no one was beating down the door of
his house to burn Copernicus at the
stake just yet
a contributing factor had to be the fact
that his book was not exactly reader
friendly Copernicus believed that
mathematics is written for
mathematicians so laymen were unlikely
to get much out of it even if they read
it it was up to other astronomers who
came afterwards to champion his cause
and bring Copernican beliefs to the
wider masses and indeed suffer the
consequences of that the basic idea was
the one initially outlined in commentary
olace according to heliocentrism the
earth was no longer special it was
simply just another planet that orbited
the Sun
[Music]
one of the aforementioned astronomers he
became a follower of Copernicus was his
pupil Jorge Joaquim de Porres he's
better known as rheticus when he was
young rheticus obtained the patronage of
philipp melanchthon an influential
Protestant reformer and Martin Luther's
right-hand man he arranged for the young
scientists to go study with some of the
greatest astronomers of his day but it
was Copernicus who garnered his true
interest in fact he might have played
the most important part in making sure
that their revolutionibus orbit and
cholesterol the light of day after
Copernicus of course he kept on
pestering and encouraging his teacher to
publish the work in 1540 with the
permission of Copernicus rheticus wrote
and published narrator a Prima the first
report it was an abstract of his
teachers heliocentric theory and served
well as an introduction to Copernicus
book which would also be released a few
years later so yes the first ever work
published on the Copernican model did
not even belong to Copernicus even so
nobody raised their pitchforks in anger
when this work came out and this proved
to be instrumental in finally convincing
the Polish astronomer to put his own
book into print in 1540 with Rika
Bernanke's finally consented to having
his magnum opus published he sent it via
rheticus to a German printer Johannes
Petraeus and the project was overseen by
theologian Andres or C anda he had
previously conversed with Copernicus and
showed an interest in his hypothesis but
it is not clear if he undertook this
task on his own or someone else's
perhaps the book was divided into six
sections mimicking closely the layout of
Ptolemy's Almagest it was dedicated to
Pope Paul the third and contained a
preface which argued that mathematics
was the basis used for these new ideas
and not physics so mathematics should be
used to understand them these were all
efforts by Copernicus to make his work
less controversial in the eyes of the
Catholic Church when the book finally
came out Copernicus couldn't help but
notice that the preface also contained a
letter that he did not write or even
know about it was titled
to the reader concerning the hypotheses
of this work and hadn't actually been
written by Ossie and ER and added to the
book without Copernicus consent the
Edition advised that the ideas put
forward in the book are not necessarily
true or even probable for that matter
but they are useful for making
observations and calculating distances
it anticipated that scholars would be
offended by the notion that the earth
moves while the Sun is at rest in the
center of the universe and came to the
defense of the author who has done
nothing blameworthy the thing about the
letter was that our siendo wrote it
anonymously and did not sign anything at
the end to the reader it looked like
Copernicus himself was the author of a
black tourim who seemingly didn't
believe his own theories
Copernicus wasn't around for long to see
the impact of his work he died of a
stroke soon after the book was published
in his home in from Bach he was 70 years
olds and legend says that he passed away
right after being presented with the
final printed pages of the book that he
had worked on for most of his life as
far as ad Lecter was concerned
rheticus and supporters of Copernicus
made sure that others knew that the
Polish scientist was not the one who
wrote it
ah see and his reason for writing it
still remains a mystery some argued that
he himself did not believe in Copernicus
theories and was offended by their
heretical implications and wanted to
dismiss the book is a legitimate work of
science others believe the exact
opposite ah see under tried to minimize
the negative reactions to the book as
much as possible and your guess here is
as good as ours regarding his true
intentions now to revolutionibus orbit
um question isn't going to be cracking
any bestseller lists anytime soon
indeed it's all terribly even in its
time because it was very technical and
not meant for anyone who didn't have a
solid background in mathematics or
astronomy the few copies that were sold
though they reached the right people and
in the decades that followed many
scientists converted to Copernicanism
computations using this new model were
unsurprisingly more accurate and proved
very useful for new astronomical tables
also unsurprising was the religious
reaction Protestants were the ones most
fired up against Copernicus Martin
Luther objected that his work went
against Holy Scripture that said that
Joshua bid the Sun to stand still and
not the earth he believed Copernicus was
a fool who wanted to turn the whole art
of astronomy upside down the Catholic
Church had lights similar but much
slower reaction and put the book on the
index of forbidden books in the early
17th century almost 70 years after it
originally came out try as they might
though the idea of heliocentrism was now
in the open
there's probably meant little to the
common man but the more and more
scientists looked at it the more and
more they realized it made sense it was
a bell that could not be unrung and our
understanding of the universe it grew
and evolved from that premise to what we
have today so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did why
not continue learning by supporting our
sponsor brilliant there is a link below
please do check them out
also subscribe to this channel we've got
brand new videos four times a week
hit that Bell so you find out when those
videos come out
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]